how you by my mama tears but I
care about is this I was in a
festival area with my balls lifted up
squatting letting this child
predator look at me this is when I'm
focus on I'm killing Mitchell I'd
already put my man
[Music]
I'm super excited to have this guy back
to told my favorite story ever on this
show you guys are gonna love him give it
up for mr. obesity everybody what
happens you take a 19 year old boy and
put him in prison it's what happens now
I'm 21 at the times I haven't settled
into the prison now I've been there for
a while but in prison you have things
that you very particular about like I
told my cellie hey no peeing standing up
in this in this sale you have to sit
down and pee because it is I pray
on the floor and so if you urinating you
splash urine all over the place
imma kill you just setting the tone so
you start developed certain type of
phobias about things um I developed this
phobia when I first got to this place
called Diagnostics in prison it's a it's
basically slavery it's like a bunch of
fences even one fence just like it's a
space for like 80 people but they ran
like 200 people in the space you're just
trying to get your space you oh nobody
behind you you want nobody but in front
of you you just want to maintain your
space so that's the first channel the
first little cage and you have own
clothes so they move you to the second
cage and they tell you to take off all
your clothes now you neck it with the
same a bunch of people smashed in so now
you're back trying to get your space you
don't want nobody behind you don't want
to buddy in front trying to get your
space do we all naked Sidhu come over
and talk to me say hey man what's going
on with you in here for
hey dude get the away from me
naked and you in my space so I'm not
really comfortable being naked with a
plethora of me and I'm not that's not
why I met with my life so moving forward
now I'm in prison and I remember
something my uncle told me he said if
you never want to be naked in prison you
buy some shorts off commissary and they
can't make you take off the shorts
because the shorts tonight contraband
cool I've been having these shorts this
was my first purchase a lot of people
purchase other things on commissary soup
and food I bought a pair of white shorts
$7 best purchase I have made in prison
so I wear these shorts every day even if
I wear my boxers I would have shorts on
under my boxes because I already know
anytime you can be strip searched and I
know the rules cuz I was a fire safety
clerk see me tell you fires this is
power I know everything about this
prison if I worked for spar bro which is
a fine safety man I'm gonna find safety
Kurt so I don't want nobody with
me
stripping down nothing so most of the
time I'm I'm a well-respected young guy
in this prison so I've been here since I
was 19
now I'm 21 and I'm just getting my
stripes officers respect me cuz I'm
respectable and I'm so respectable that
officers don't do this when they call
this sustain they called Chow time
that's what people run out to the door
to go eat like cattle
I said hey don't talk to me like that
I'm a civilized human being and officers
like Oh child time do that to our alley
excuse me lunch for you I like thank you
sir it's gone very civilized so now I'm
about to become uncivilized because it's
an officer named Mitch it's always
somebody when a bunch of people like you
is always somebody who doesn't like you
and they trying to prove a point so
Mitchell sees me and let me tell you who
Mitchell look like Mitchell look like
the dude what's do Flanders on the same
who's always like a pedophile to
me always so I'm coming through for no
random reason Mitchell pulls me over in
this area I'm gonna building ages why
stay at an inn it's a it's a
high-traffic area the vegetable area he
stops me in the vegetable area
and say hey I think you had some
contraband I'm gonna shake you down like
yo Mitchell I just came from necessities
I don't have no contraband get
the out here you know and put your
hands down
why are you talking to me because you
supposed to stay three feet away from me
because you know I'm gonna find
a safety clerk so don't break
the rules so we say well I'm a
strip-search you I'm like no you're not
not in this high-traffic area no you're
not sir so he calls the rest of these
other offices around some
rookies that don't know me and he's like
yo we gonna have to take off your
clothes so I took off all of they white
they clothes gave it to him nothing
I got my shorts on I'm standing there he
said you're gonna take some shorts off I
say that's not the rules Mitchell
that's rows
and now I'm getting a little a little
heated about this because I know I have
a problem with being naked in the
hallway and I know that I have
problems with this and I'm and I'm
trying to get Mitchell to understand
Mitchell this is not gonna be good
Mitchell Mitchell Mitchell I'm trying to
explain in Mitchell Mitchell so he gets
all the rest of these offices around the
captain comes up and says I'm I can't go
against my officer
he said you got contraband you're gonna
have to get naked I say captain if I get
naked in this hallway in front of all
these people coming in and out and I
turn right to mention looked in the
men's eyes and say this ain't gonna be
good at Mitchell because I don't give a
about going home at this point
I came here with 15 years Mitchell I
won't do these love 15 years and go home
but if you make me get naked in this
festival area so they got
all these officers around me and I
didn't threaten this man with the
easiest way I can threaten me without
getting sent to sea I said men should
say gonna be good brother
so long story short I ended up naked and
I'm pissed I'm naked and I'm bald-headed
and he do he taking me through this
run your fingers through your
hair open your mouth
I've been talking this whole time if
something was in my mouth Mitchell it
have been fell out open your mouth
lift up your balls squat let me explain
what he just did I went to prison for a
nonviolent case drug Dylan what he just
turned me into was a violent young man
at 21 because you made me confident
squat for no reason other than
that you wanted to see me in my mind
so now I got tears in my eyes and people
walking past other prisons walking past
and they looking at Mitchell like
Mitchell this ain't gonna be good so for
eight months I've been planning on
killing Mitchell
like I don't wrote my mama this code it
is coded letter letting them know that I
son ain't coming home no more I told
this Rob wrote the letter I said mama
prisons like judicial slavery I just
figured this out and I'm that Turner you
had nobody history no y'all if y'all
will figure it out and my mom writes me
a letter back like just chill and she
got a face with tears on the face and
I'm like looking honey but like I'll get
by my mama tears but I care about
is this I was in the festival
area with my balls lifted up squatting
coughing letting this
child predator look at me this is what
I'm focus on I'm killing
Mitchell I'd already put in my mind it's
done so I didn't told two people I told
two people al-amin his name is Leslie
Davis and Mustafa
I don't know Mustafa's name but I was so
terrified of myself I never wanted to
ask him his real name goes dead what
happened somebody buzzes with something
else in prison who said did I know his
real name did his back on me do you
wanna know so I told my stuff what stuff
was like yeah that was fine with
Mitchell did but stopping being here for
27 years if I killed somebody I know he
damn alameen got 50 years he ain't going
nowhere I plan on spending the rest of
my life with al-amin and will stop
cuz I'm gonna keep Mitchell I already
notice don't know how but like anything
in my life something is gonna break this
dude I'm coming from eating this dude's
say Haley I said what's up man
he said you know Mitchell is working the
for game I said but now my dropping in
prison I haven't been happy about
nothing a long time the man told me that
he was working for Kate
I got excited let me tell you
what for Katie is for game is to get to
closed custody
I live on eight building you got to go
to four building if you're going to
close custody when you come around the
corner in Fort building it's like you
gotta come pass the cafeteria and then
it's the main building this way and then
it's too slow side hallway and you can't
see anybody until you come around that
corner and Mitchell's at a gate around
that corner which is a good day he's not
gonna make it if I get to him he's not
gonna make it and then it's that gate
and then it's the gate to for building
so it's a long wait to get to him
there's another long way to get to that
door I got a plan imma just run and just
just try to get through that
gate understand Mitchell but that's
stupid that's good so
I go back to my cell and I'm sitting I'm
trying to map out a plan on why I could
kill his due and then I hear get
ready to go to for building I look out
myself
don't it's a dude that got in trouble
now he's getting sent before a building
he has this big white bucket with all
this in it
and I say hey you going to fall building
you say yeah I say let me carry your
mattress for you you say cool I need
some help I go up the stairs get my
knife put my strap my on me boom I
got a big hands mattress over my
shoulder so you can't see my face he's
rolling the bucket mattress over me come
around the building and I'm so
excited because I'm going to kill
Mitchell and I'm a drinker sip his blood
cuz I hated that when they find
me I'll be like yeah oh my hey wait I'm
so violent so got this knife and I'm got
this mattress and this dude it mean - he
has no idea what's gonna happen
he's accessory to this crime and he is
so unaware he just rolled it he rolled
his bucket talking about his family man
I miss up my family i went to
visit me I'm like good my name either
so we coming around the bill we coming
past Town Hall and I'm just
getting more and more excited cuz this
is gonna be a good one
somebody apparently tell cuz alameen
looking for me apparently he said yeah
why yeah he say
Eileen helped old boy move the for
building and Mostafa could I give this
all the backstory Mostafa say yeah he's
going to fall building and Leslie I mean
say a mouthing Mitchell on for building
but start to say Mitchell on for
building man let's go get this boy cuz
he gonna kill Mitchell now it's
complicated
cuz they got to get out of 8 building
first you got to get out of ages we got
to get bullets out your part come out of
a building I'm thinking I'm good I got
enough time commit this murder and
hopefully get away with it as I said his
blood so he coming around the corner the
dude has the bucket he's going through
Mitchell opens the gate but he don't see
me he can't see me cuz I have the
mattress over my shoulder and as the
bucket goes through the gate it's the
Panthers clear me all I gotta do is wait
for that bunkie to get out the way then
Mitchell be staying at the edge decade I
can walk through my mattress and just
start stabbing Mitchell
uncontrollably
this is lumpy I got it planned out my
head I'm dead serious
so I come I'm right there and as soon as
I get to I can see Mitchell
al-amin and Mustapha come around the
hallway and say I'll leave and I
turn and look and Mitchell sees me and
slams the gate and tell me to put the
mattress down he can take his own Mack
put the mattress down and I'm standing
there looking at him say hey Mitchell
and he just stayed put the mattress down
I sleep the matches off my shoulder I
say you have a good day Mitchell and
just the terror in his eyes and
I know he's on himself Jesse look
was enough for me and I just walked away
real slow with and didn't bring I
contact since I got to al-amin
[Applause]
[Music]